now I don't know what it is about us
women but we just have an inclination to
never be happy and to nitpick into wine
you know a man men are just generally
more content with life like they'll have
a good job good benefits and they'll say
okay I'm a happy camper but women just
we have a tendency to want it doesn't
mean we're bad people but I mean I think
we can acknowledge there's some pattern
and one pattern I notice is women will
want to be in a man's world they'll say
please let me into a man's world oh
please God please God let me in I want
to be in and then they get in and they
tell men how to talk they start policing
the language you can't say that this is
bullying